hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to you with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make
learning math a lot less stressful so in
this video what we're going to talk
about is how to find the area of
trapezoids okay so what exactly is a
trapezoid well a trapezoid is a
quadrilateral meaning it has four sides
with one pair of opposite sides parallel
okay so you can see that these are
parallel but these are not parallel okay
and when you find the area what you do
is you take one-half times the height
the height is the perpendicular distance
between these two parallel sides which
are referred to as the bases and then
you multiply times the sum of the two
bases so it's base one plus base two
times the height times one-half and that
gives you the area of the trapezoid so
let's look at some examples and you'll
get a sense of how this works so in this
one here you can see here's our parallel
sides these are going to be our bases
all we have to do is go ahead and
substitute we have one half the height
is 4 and the two bases are going to be 8
and 12 so we just have to add those
together so that's gonna be 20 times 1/2
is 10 times 4 is 40 so this is going to
be 40 units squared and that's the exact
area of the trapezoid okay let's take a
look at another example now in this
example it's a little bit more
challenging right we know that base 1 we
don't know what Beast 2 is and we don't
know what the height is but they give us
a little clue they tell us that this
angle here is 45 degrees so if you know
your 45-45-90 triangles it's going to be
easy to figure out they're in the ratio
of X X X square root of 2 okay if you
want you can check out my video on the
special right triangles I'll have a link
for that up above but basically if this
is 5 root 2 that tells us that this side
is going to be 5 this side here is going
to be 5 this is going to be 8 see how
we've sectioned this off into a
rectangle so the opposite sides are
congruent so that means that this whole
base here is going to be 13 ok
and now we can use our area formula so
it's going to be area equals
1/2 times the height which is 5 times
the sum of the bases which is going to
be 13 plus 8 okay so if we go and
simplify that down what do we get we've
got 13 plus 8 which is 21 okay times 5
which is 105 divided by 2 which is 52
point five right so 52 point 5 units
squared that's going to give us an area
of the trapezoid so I hope you enjoyed
this video I hope you learned something
go ahead and subscribe to the channel
check out some of my past videos and
I've got more videos like this coming
for you so I'll talk to you in the next
video I'll talk to you soon